Через масовані обстріли Росією енергетичної інфраструктури України
енергетики змушені вдаватися до планових та екстрених відключень світла цілих мікрорайонів.
Не працюють вуличні ліхтарі та світлофори.
Унаслідок цього суттєво зросла кількість ДТП із пішоходами у темну пору доби.
Якщо говорити мовою цифр - 716 дорожньо-транспортних пригод за участю пішоходів,
там, де є потерпілі і загиблі саме пішоходи, трапилося за цей місяць - з 10 жовтня по 10 листопада.
І в цих 716 ДТП загинуло 135 людей, пішоходів. З них понад 75%, 102 людини, загинули в темну пору доби.
Проблема у тому, що через відсутність освітлення водії не встигають відреагувати на появу пішохода.
Людина, одягнена у темний одяг, може бути або взагалі непомітною для водія,
або стати видимою лише на відстані 10-18 метрів.
Цієї відстані недостатньо, аби загальмувати.
Щоб убезпечити себе, перш за все треба себе позначити.
Як це зробити? Перше, що рекомендуємо, це світлий одяг: білий, жовтий колір найкраще видно на дорозі,
це може бути дистанція 50-80 метрів.
Ну, а найкраще діють, звісно ж, світловідбиваючі елементи.
Це можуть бути жилети, це може бути елементарна стрічка.
От дослідження говорять, що площа світловідбиваючого елемента має бути не меншою ніж 15 см.
Тоді це вже певна видимість на дорозі.
Світловідбивачі найкраще почепити на рухомі ділянки тіла - руки та ноги, у дітей - на верхню частину тулуба.
Тоді пішохода буде видно за 130 метрів і більше.
Ми вирішили провести власний експеримент і перевірити,
наскільки водієві буде видно мене на дорозі, якщо я переходитиму її у світлій куртці і у темній.
Бачимо, що на відстані 40 метрів від пішохідного переходу моя світла куртка добре відбиває світло фар,
і водій може вчасно мене помітити.
А ось інша спроба: на тій самій відстані, але у темній куртці, мене ледь помітно.
А коли немає освітлення від фар інших автівок - взагалі не видно.
Схожі експерименти провели й патрульні поліцейські.
На цьому відео одночасно переходять дорогу пішоходи у світлому одязі, темному та зі світловідбивачами.
Саме так виглядають для водія пішоходи на відстані 30 метрів при увімкненому ближньому світлі фар.
На ньому можна розгледіти максимум трьох людей. А тепер подивіться, скільки їх було насправді.
Аби запобігти аварійним ситуаціям, пішоходам обов’язково потрібно якось себе позначити.
Хоча би підсвітити себе ліхтариком на телефоні.
А водіям у місті радять принципово знизити швидкість.
Адже з цим в Україні проблеми - водіїв не штрафують за перевищення швидкості до 20 км/год.
У нас з 1984 року, я прослідкував це в Кодексі України "Про адміністративні порушення", була прописана ця норма.
Справа в тому, що ці 20 км/год дуже впливають на аварійність, дуже впливають на безпеку.
Якщо ми порахуємо на сухій дорозі зупинковий шлях автомобіля при швидкості 50 км/год – він буде десь 34 метри.
Якщо ми порахуємо при швидкості 70 км/год – він практично вдвічі збільшується, практично вдвічі.
І якщо поєднати це з іншими факторами - відсутністю вуличного освітлення,
світловідбивачів на пішоходах та вимкненими світлофорами, то ймовірність аварій суттєво збільшується.
За підрахунками експертів з дорожньої безпеки, Україна займає перше місце у Європі за смертністю на дорогах.
Понад 40% усіх ДТП з потерпілими і загиблими за минулий рік сталися через перевищення швидкості руху.
До речі, хочу сказати, що ця норма +20, скажемо так, залишилася в Україні і в РФ.
У багатьох, скажімо так, в усіх країнах Європейського Союзу, які ми досліджували, які ми бачили,
такої норми перевищення на 20 км законної нібито швидкості не існує як такої.
У багатьох країнах світу є ця толерантність, але десь це є 5 км/год, десь це, от я знаю для автобанів 13 чи 14 км/год, десь 10.
Тобто все це залежить від засобів вимірювання, які розповсюджені в цій країні,
ну і, зрозуміло, від законодавчих норм, які були прийняті раніше. Так, є ті країни, де нуль.
Щоб контролювати швидкість водіїв, в Україні працюють камери автоматичної фіксації там, де це зараз можливо.
У разі ДТП навіть якщо водій перевищив до 20 км/год, він все одно понесе відповідальність - адміністративну чи кримінальну.
Тим не менше, експерти з безпеки руху переконані, що законодавство необхідно вдосконалити.
Зараз я знаю, що організація ЦЕДЕМ розробляє законопроєкт щодо штрафних балів.
Тобто якщо людина буде перевищувати швидкість постійно - йому будуть нараховуватися певні штрафні бали,
і він має бути позбавлений права керування транспортним засобом.
Це дуже вплине на водіїв, на мою думку, і на їхню законослухняність.
На безпеку на дорогах в зимовий період також суттєво впливає, чи переходять водії з літніх шин на зимові.
Це безпосередньо впливає на гальмівний шлях автомобіля.
Крім того, патрульні радять водіям пригадати правила проїзду нерегульованих світлофорами перехресть і сигнали регулювальника.
Адже на основних перехрестях, якщо світлофор вимкнений, рух мають регулювати вручну.